good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
wednesday hump day sorry this is like
the third hump day in a row theo hasn't
been here but i'm recording my audiobook
after the show today so i could not
bring theo because
i'm a busy author that's true and i
guess that means spoiler alert theo
won't be on the audiobook
i don't know i wouldn't you know i
wouldn't say anything i was so crazy i
wouldn't rule anything out
no you know what what happens in the
booth doesn't stay in the booth and i
just will say like if you wanted to do a
dog audio book like i know one one boy
who would listen to it
it would go something like
[Music]
arf with no job we have a big ass
juicy ass juicy double show for you
today
it's wednesday which means we have our
famous our beloved
advice segment dear toasters where you
can submit any sort of advice queries to
your toasters at gmail.com we have the
bachelorette recap
after jail after deal we have the fast
five
chock full of goodies we do and i did
finish the crown but i know that you
didn't so i will do
everything i can to not talk about it
i'll steer you away i will try to watch
today as much as possible i literally
have
did you watch any yesterday no i've had
such a busy week yesterday i had such a
busy day you know that
god bless you excuse me you sneezed on
it you know that bruno sweets like keeps
me on my toes
all damn day long um but i just like had
so much going on
i went to the live method yesterday and
something so sad happened to me you fell
worse oh i banged my head oh [ __ ] that's
the [ __ ]
worse and there's no bruising or
anything but like it hurts to the touch
and internal bleeding it was just so
embarrassing
yeah that's like i it hurt it hurt but
like it wasn't
blind so i was doing sit-ups while i
held a kettlebell
and every time i sat up i had to put the
bell up and on one of the ones up it
just like
kettlebell that like weighs 50 pounds
you think you have a concussion they
have different
weighted kettlebells do you think you
have a condition no i don't because it
didn't hurt that badly but it was just
like
the shock of the pain and the
embarrassment yeah like i was just like
to matt like
i need a second i just went in a single
tear
a little tear stream down my face but i
don't think anyone saw that's the thing
about like
hurting yourself in public the
humiliation and the shame
hurts way more than the physical you
know bump or bruise
and it's the shock of like oh wow i was
doing sit-ups and now i hit my head
no and it's the shock of like i'm
supposed to be like a coordinated adult
i'm like just over here banging my head
on things
yeah it was it was quite shocking but i
powered through the rest of the workout
um i'm so sorry that happened too that's
awful yeah it just sort of like colored
my day
and now i woke up this morning and like
when i was doing my makeup like i could
feel
the bruise on my head but i think i
think it's okay hopefully
hopefully yeah but you know so far so
good some of you on the youtube channel
might have noticed jackie and i
looking extra fabulous actually a new
merch that might look familiar from last
holiday drop we have revamped
our toasty lights best-selling internet
breaking jonas brothers music video
making
sweatshirt now it's coming in a hoodie
which is i which is what i am wearing a
black hoodie
i'm wearing a white long sleeve and to
make things even more exciting
matching phone cases and mugs for our
toasty lights
collection all of our new merch which we
will be showing you
all week so just make sure you're
watching on youtube because you're going
to see some fire looks from us
all of our holiday merch is dropping
this friday so
it's friday make it your calendar to set
your calendars there is
we wanted everyone to be able to get
everything in time for the holidays so
there is a good amount of inventory but
a limited stock so make sure you're just
on shopmorningtoast.com
friday watch the show you'll have all
the information that you need
and there's tons of new stuff which will
be a sneak peek in pretty much every day
very exciting like some super christmasy
holiday stuff i love this um
design because i feel like this font is
so christmassy like it's so
like the opening title for a christmas
movie i literally feel like an
elf just like wrote it no i completely
agree and we have some other really fun
holiday items some more like evergreen
items if you want to get a gift for your
friend if you want to like
really start to feel like the holidays
are here we've talked about cultivating
a vibe you can light a candle you can
play christmas music
and you can wear toasty holiday merch
there's nothing better
absolutely nothing and i feel like today
it's also so cold out
what the [ __ ] literally if i i can't
keep up
like with the climate change changing
like it's exhausting i know and now that
i
am so like weather dependent because i
take bruno sweets out
it's just freaking cold out here i know
and it's like
having a puppy in the winter so hard
because you really have to stand outside
for very long periods yesterday
was one of those days and now i'm i'm on
earmuff like i'm in the earmuff phase of
my life it's funny
i didn't even wear a coat today yeah i
feel like if i didn't have a dog i'd be
like it's beautiful out yeah no
honestly like coming to work with theo
and coming to work without theo are two
different lifestyles and like
as much as i love having them here just
like being able to like breeze my way
through manhattan
and doing whatever i please it's such a
joy but i do miss you of course
of course i miss him so much and his
absence is keenly felt today but i feel
like we should just you know
make it so good like in honor of him i
feel like we should get into it because
we have like a very busy day ahead of us
okay of toastiness we have a very busy
day of toastiness and so without further
ado here are the past five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and that may be true but i feel like
powering my story today jackie do you
always thank god that vega is one of
today's sponsors because they
want you to power your story they have
one goal to help you power your story
with premium plant-based nutrition
that enables you to feel and perform
your best learn about how to power your
story
with vega at myvega.com toast
vega products provide convenience
without compromise so you can always
power your story with the plant-based
nutrition you need on the go
learn more at myvega.com toast
if you're looking to upgrade your daily
smoothie or level up your afternoon
snack
vega has you covered from protein
powders to bars made with real
plant-based ingredients
power your story with the number one
plant-based protein powder brand in
north america
where you can learn more at myvega.com
toast
if you're looking to dial in your
nutrition at every stage of your
training the vegas sportline is made
with real plant-based ingredients and
offers products for pre-mid
and post-workout dial in your nutrition
and power your story with vega sport
learn more about how to power your story
with vega at myvega.com
toast y v e g a dot com slash
toast sign on power your morning so is
the first story um
people's sexy man alive i have managed
to
not find out who it is you're lying no i
swear because this morning i was
actually thinking like last night like
i know it's coming out soon but i fell
asleep at 10 o'clock then when i woke up
i'm like i'm not gonna like go on
twitter and i'm not gonna look because i
want to be surprised and i want to guess
but you were you really haven't seen
really haven't seen oh my gosh
okay so i'm thinking you get three
guesses no clues
three guesses no clues okay
um like it's hard because no one was
like a clear like star this year because
nothing happened but like
that's true someone who's just like hot
all the time like michael b jordan yeah
that's it oh no way yep no i'm kidding i
know
[Laughter]
i don't know why like i thought that was
so funny
did it was i being like a good actress
and i was like hmm my gummy jordan
yeah no i like i you really i mean i
never would have guessed that that you
would put on you believed me 100
why wouldn't i why wouldn't i believe
you
i don't know i'm a trusting person well
when i woke up this morning i actually
didn't know yet i'm like you know what
it'll be funny if like i could find out
like and get like a genuine surprise but
then i just got too curious so i looked
on twitter oh wow curiosity killed the
cat
curiosity it truly got the best of me
it broke her heart now all that's left
if she
this is a this is a great choice yes
michael b jordan is people's sexiest man
alive and
for 2020. he said the women in my family
are proud of this one
so michael b jordan is by all
definitions like the sexiest man alive
yeah period a lot of times like people
you know takes creative liberties
like this man's personality is so sexy
yeah no sometimes there have been many a
controversial selects
i think most recently obviously blake
shelton was but like a curious one
last year was john legend which was also
like not the obvious choice
a good one yeah a good one but i don't
really think of john legend as like
super sexy like i think of him as very
talented and like funny and like part of
a good marriage
that's why it was it was an interesting
choice it wasn't the obvious choice no
this is very obvious this is very
obvious he is very sexy
he tells people that it's a cool feeling
you know everybody always made that joke
like mike this is the one thing you're
probably never going to get but it's a
good club to be a part of who would say
that no
what [ __ ] are you hanging out yeah
like no like it's like very much in the
realm of possibility for michael b
jordan
it would be more impossible for him to
never get this right than for him to
have gotten it
i think my favorite thing about michael
b jordan is that i knew about him before
everyone else because like i used to
watch friday night lights like when it
was on the air and that's where he came
from and a lot of people forget but
i never forgot no i think people
remember and i don't think so
i think i'm the only one okay well
congratulations to you thank you this is
such a big day for me the photos are
stunning exactly
beautiful stunning smart and incredibly
sexy
i would hope so yes so make sure to pick
up a copy of people magazine
and who are some of the honorable
mentions i saw dan levy got one
honorable mentions
which i think they give sexiest hair
sexiest foot oh yeah sexy
these are just like other sexy people
right but not the
sexy man no they're not the sexiest man
alive but they're sexy men
living yeah chris breathing lives sexy
men
you know it's like when you like those
knees outside
sexy yeah you know those neon signs it
was like nude girls live walking
like we should open a club like sexy
breathing oxygen men
and here would be the features chris
evans
of course dwayne johnson he's the former
sexiest and now he's just among the sexy
he's been demoted i have to say like i
while dwayne johnson i don't think is my
type like i'm not into like
enormous dudes there's something about
him that is very sexy no he is so sexy
period period paul mezcal from normal
people
the love of my life like if you haven't
seen that show you guys and you're
looking for some
for some sort of sexual awakening watch
that show because paul mezcal is
everything of the sort oh we were
talking about the girl
yesterday she's in where the crawdad
sing and he's
certifiably sexy and he was nominated
for an emmy so i feel like he's having a
good year
for sure maluma very sexy very sexy
pedro pascal from the mandalorian
i don't didn't see it don't know who
that is chris rock he's sexy
paul rudd are people going to move on
that was such a great reaction
because i love paul rudd like i love his
movies he's amazing and friends and like
he is super super cute
but just like let's move on yeah um also
pedro pascal
is from game of thrones remember he
spoiler alert
has his face smashed in yes yes yes yes
yes
um john david washington who's from
tennant which was like a big movie this
year one of the few that
were able to be movies oh yes actually i
was just at dinner with friends and they
were talking about how it was
truly one of the worst movies they ever
saw and had made no sense no plot like
no nothing yeah
brad pitt always sexy classic sexy guy
never not sexy manny jacinto from the
good place okay
and then those are so those were the 10
extra sexy the bonus sexy
right but do you want to get sexiest
food yeah like they have such specific
categories
yeah like sexy hair like like sexy as
clothes
yeah no way i agree with you sees late
night host on abc
like they get really specific yeah we're
gonna find out who
are the specific sexy people yeah
sexiest late night host that's what you
know
in one year no andy got sexy's hair oh
nice and i think he was really proud of
that he does have nice hair
are you struggling to find the article
i'm just like yeah i want to find the
one that's like all the
um maybe it only comes out in the actual
issue we should pick up a copy
we should i'm just gonna go to their
sexiest man live tab and like see if
it's there and then if not i'll move on
okay from all the sexiness because john
mayer should be in there
something whenever a report on this
story i feel like anna faris in the
house bunny
so sexy yeah by the way also i can't
believe just like
not that i don't have anything bad to
say about people's sexiest man alive
and they do the most beautiful woman
issue but i
do find it hard to believe that this
whole saga hasn't been canceled yet like
something about it feels wrong i can't
put my finger on but i do
also like kind of enjoy it like it's
exciting who's going to be like it still
holds some sort of
excitement totally i just feel like that
and like maxim hot 100 like
i just find that in 2020 like someone
would have found a way to make this
controversial do you know what i mean
for sure like pitting women against
women and then
separating it by gender like i just
can't believe it's still a thing
for sure the specific sexiness
hasn't it's not out yet oh okay so we'll
have to pick up a physical copy maybe
next time i'm in the airport or maybe
tomorrow we'll get like
we'll find out who has the sexiest food
maybe we'll say i'm really looking
forward to the foot category
it's one of my favorites every year well
congratulations to all of the sexy men
you're so sexy so sexy so so sexy
happy for michael b jordan yeah no this
is so deserved like he's so sexy
and there was also a few years where
they were just like rotating the same
three guys
yeah and that was like when i feel as
though they really could have faded into
a relevancy
but they got with the times and started
choosing out of like literally just
george clooney and brad pitt like
that's what they used to do every year
yeah yeah and i feel like and
most beautiful woman is always julia
roberts yeah even though i think she
like literally got it once but for some
reason it's like she's ingrained in my
mind it's like
people always choosing her as the most
beautiful woman yeah i agree with that
okay ready for our next story it's
really some sad news oh no
jessie nelson takes an extended break
from little mix for quote medical
reasons
so tell the little mix stands out there
um i'm not gonna lie i speak on behalf
of all of us like i really didn't see
this one coming
right now they're in the middle of
putting out like fire singles lead up to
an album
and jesse is taking on a break in a
statement received by the bbc on tuesday
it was said that quote jesse is having
extended time off from little mix for
private medical reasons
we will not be issuing any further
comment currently and ask media to
please respect her privacy during this
time
well i really really hope that she's
okay and like this truly is just like a
medical break like people need breaks
all the time for medical reasons
taking breaks and we just read a book
for the redheads um the unraveling of
cassidy homes which is about a girl
group and
like all of the things that go on behind
the scenes
and take a break if you need a break
take a break please but when it comes to
like very famous groups when someone
leaves like
people are always speculation and
speculation and i do believe i've said
here
once or twice it might have been on the
morning breath when i had the esteemed
privilege of going to a private little
mix concert and then like interviewing
them afterwards i really felt like i got
their vibe
and the vibe that i got and i remember
saying this i said if they ever break up
it'll be because
jessie leaves like i just got a vibe
that they were like leaving her out and
like she was just like different from
them
not saying that that's what this is but
if it is i just wanted to put it out
there that i called it first
great i'm happy for you yeah this is bad
for the fans it's important to get
credit for your
predictions she also missed out on the
girl groups the search final they have a
show
little mix the search she missed out on
the final um
episode in their performance at the mtv
europe music awards saying jessie is
unwell and will not be appearing on
tonight's final no she will also not be
hosting or performing at tomorrow's
mtv emas i do like performing without
her
so they performed without her at the
ema's that's crazy yeah they perform
sweet melody
i feel like i'm going to take this at
face value and
say that this is exactly what's going on
because i feel like if it was something
bigger they would have like come up with
a more elaborate
statement ex you know what i mean but
like just being like it's medical
bug off yeah i'm gonna accept that and
i'm going and i'm going to bug off and
jesse like if you're listening
um i wish you a speedy recovery and and
i hope whatever it is
that you're going through like isn't
that serious because it sounds scary
like the way that they describe it yeah
totally yes i agree i think we should
take this at face value and just
time will tell if this is really what's
going on and also like
i think that in order for our favorite
bands to stay our favorite bands we need
to normalize people taking breaks like
actual breaks
sometimes you just need a pause yeah of
course but then it's like our trust
is betrayed because one direction says
they're going on a brief hiatus and it's
been six years
yeah no but maybe if like they took the
break when they needed to it wouldn't
they wouldn't need six years off but
that's not our fault we should normalize
music and industry executives
letting 17 year olds go on breaks but
right if but if this is like our first
instance of it of getting the break when
the break is needed we need to show the
music executives that we're good with it
that we are happy for them
and that we are fine with breaks if
people are coming yes but at the end of
the day
it's not in our power it's the music
exactly even that documentary where was
like one direction was on this
non-stop tour waking up every night in
the middle of the night recording their
new album for the next tour
so by the time this tour is over they
will release the album and then go on
another tour and spend two weeks at home
like
that is awful and that has nothing to do
with the fans like that has everything
to do with the simon cowells of the
world who plan these things
yeah but maybe like enough like enough
one directions have broken up that
they're like okay maybe we'll try it
differently this time if someone maybe
if someone needs a break we will give
them a break because we'd rather have a
short-term break
than the dissolution of the band of
course maybe that'll work right you
would think these big wigs you would
think that they would be like
not so short-sighted yeah but big wigs i
don't know maybe their wigs are on too
tight because they can't see anything
but like the next
the next day they can't see anything
long-term their wigs are on
too tight they are okay next story
claudia's
favorite guy conan o'brien is ending his
nightly tbs show in 2021
only interesting because he's moving
well only semi-interesting because he's
moving to a weekly variety show on hbo
max
so this is a an example of a traditional
late night host
choosing streaming service over cable
late night format which has always been
the dream for people
yeah i do have to say this like is an
interesting case study
but not that interesting because it's
not like conan o'brien walked away from
like a big-ass show like
he's on tbs and he like got that show
as like a favor after that whole jay
leno thing happened like it's not like
jimmy fallon jimmy kimmel james corden
like one of the big ones went
like conan is pretty irrelevant if
if i'm being honest so yes this is a big
win for the streaming awards but
i don't i don't want to say this without
being mean but like conan's a loser you
know what i mean
yeah wait there's a quote here and i'm
not sure if it's a joke
because if it's a joke it's hysterical
what website um hollywood reporter
apparently this is what conan said in
1993 johnny carson gave me the best
advice of my career
as soon as possible get to a streaming
platform
that's funny and obviously not true
because there were no streaming
platforms
right but that is so funny wow conan is
funny no i know
he said i'm thrilled to take it back
yeah he said i'm thrilled that i get to
continue doing whatever the hell it is i
do on hbo max we agree and they look
forward to a free subscription what i
meant
is basically that like conan no matter
like he's probably like a funny guy 100
and i didn't mean to you know knock him
what
wait i'm like so just this article he
also has a a special like a traveling
special called conan without borders
wow that's pretty funny right [ __ ] do we
have to get into conan
we might have to and of course we are a
podcast who that supports other podcasts
so get me started um
okay maybe i take back all the mean
things i just said about conan because
that was pretty funny
but all i meant was like this does this
isn't that impactful because it's not
like the loss of
conan's cable show it's like oh no like
spooky we're fine like yeah the late
night
ear like category is going to be fine
yeah no i hear what you're saying it's
not like
one of the jimmy's or andy cohen or even
someone with like a remotely
like large audience of devoted fans i
think he has
some fans but i hear what you're saying
he's not one of like the biggest in but
he's
he's pretty big no if any of the jimmy's
or andy cohen or even like
samantha b like went like that would be
impressive i think samantha b
is conan conan level actually i agree
with you i think they're on the same
network that's why
yeah like james corden yeah of course
stephen colbert
well john oliver is already on streaming
well no he's on hbo yeah not hpo max
so yeah like this is if more people
follow him which i don't know if
if they will then it's interesting but
for right now i don't think it's
that big of a deal because i don't know
how many how much you know
um of a future the conan cable show had
you know i just i
might your ipad's playing music oh my
god
amateur hollywood reporter in their ads
coming for me it's tough times for
everyone like all these websites that
i'm on these days it's like
pop papa papa pop up ads cars cars cars
chill the [ __ ] out
i know like we're all going through
tough times we're all doing branded
deals we don't want to be doing but like
chill
but like speaking of do we have an app
oh
that was it's a great segue at new x
at new x our mission is to provide our
customers with the highest quality
products at a reasonable price
so a bunch of you guys actually always
ask me about my cbd experience and nuex
is one of the brands that i really love
because they make the great tasting
gummy bears
and i just find cbd um especially in the
beginning like to be like a little
intimidating
when it comes in a gummy bear it's like
not that intimidating
um new x has years of experience in
sourcing manufacturing and development
their goal is to make cbd accessible to
the masses they never sacrifice quality
and their products are natural pure and
tested the gummies taste great they have
15 milligrams of broad spectrum cbd
per gummy bear they're vegan and made
with all natural flavors
they have no art artificial colors
flavors or sweeteners thc
free it's usa grown hemp lab tested and
the best part it's under 10
perfect for people who are looking to
have a fun way of taking cbd
and for someone who maybe prefers a
sweeter method of a cbd intake
the price is just 9.99 and the best part
is that the gummy bears have a
consistent dose every time so i've taken
gummy bears
um from cbd companies that like don't
tell you how much is in each
gummy bear just in like the whole pack
which is a little freaky so i didn't
really like that
um that's why i prefer new x and if you
want to visit new x and you
x dot com to purchase some of their
great products and you can
you can use the discount code toast for
20 off for a limited time
new off new x also offers an entire
collection of on the go that offers all
products for under a 10
price point which is perfect for those
trying to take cbd for the first time
again that's nu-x dot com
promo code toast for 20 off but only for
a limited time so make sure you get on
that
love it okay next story is some business
it's been a minute
oh my god thank god i forgot my glasses
today though what do you mean
biz news i gotta put my glasses on yeah
otherwise how will you
how would you read it from my voice no
otherwise like how will i
be able to give good business advice
that's true and maybe i could give good
business advice but who would take it
from someone not wearing glasses that's
true but i don't know if we'll need your
um i guess we'll we'll need something
let me hear you amazon is opening an
online pharmacy
shaking up another industry to me i read
this and i was like
hallelujah this is what i need um i
think this is just like a no-brainer
the retail colossus opened an online
pharmacy on tuesday that allows
customers to order medication or
prescription refills
and have them delivered to their front
door in a couple of days the potential
impact of amazon's arrival in the
pharmaceutical space
rippled through that sector immediately
the stocks of cbs walgreens and writing
all tumbled on tuesday those big chains
rely on their pharmacies for a steady
flow of shoppers who may also grab a
snack or shampoo or groceries on the way
out
all have upped online services and
touted their abilities to deliver
prescriptions and other goods
as the pandemic has pushed more
consumers to stay at home but amazon has
mastered these things and its online
store is infinitely larger with millions
of loyal shoppers
already buying books tvs claudia's book
and just about anything else
yeah girls no job.com book you can get
my book on amazon okay now i have a
probably like a controversial um opinion
on just like the amazon
takeover okay because i'm a consumer at
heart you know i buy things all the time
pretty much every day and i buy things
from stores brick and mortar i buy
things from amazon
and the experience of buying something
on amazon is just so superior in
every way price user experience
speed efficiency step checkout remembers
where you like what your last address
was you have all of your like
they just you don't have so easy so as
much as everyone's like oh amazon's
taking over the brick and mortar mom and
pop and it is sad it is
as a consumer like i want the best
possible experience so the fact that
amazon is now
my prime user for deliveries for
electronics and now maybe pharmacies
like
i really can't be mad like it's fabulous
no so
much complication benefits the consumer
yeah and i agree
especially for the pharmacy like i find
calling in my prescription getting to
the pharmacy and the time before they
like
unpack my prescription to be like
extremely like
stressful for me like i just i don't
know i i dread having to call in my
prescription no and
by the way try calling your pharmacy and
then getting to the actual pharmacist
like
it's just a machine and then maybe you
get a customer service representative
who's not a part of the pharmacy and
then the pharmacy hours are so specific
even though the place is open 24 hours
and they
say they do say that i could have my
prescriptions delivered and that there's
like
a place that delivers prescriptions i
just i have yet to encounter this
in a meaningful way yeah and i feel like
i know a few days before i need a
prescription refilled and that's how
long amazon takes to get to me yeah and
i just like
i'm so here for this yeah i mean it has
been a really difficult year for small
businesses so i feel like this is like
another blow
to small businesses because yes there
are cvs's and walgreens that'll survive
but there are a lot of like general
stores and small pharmacies that are
mom and pop and like small businesses
and that sucks because amazon has
already been so destructive
towards small businesses and given
what's been going on this year like that
sucks but as a the consumer at heart
like
i ain't mad like yeah that amazon's just
taking over like every sector i
i'm gonna go out on a limb like i
[ __ ] love amazon like and i feel like
amazon's the devil to so many people but
i love it and i love jeff bezos thank
you for making my life so easy and
affordable yeah no i mean i i hear what
you're saying and
i think that this one specifically is
just it's a good it's a good thing
it's a good one yeah okay ready for our
fifth and final story
always because the first look at matt
james's season of the bachelor has been
revealed
yes as i was watching the bachelor last
night they kept teasing
the teaser and the teaser was in the big
show guys this guy which is good which
looks good but it looks like a drama
that
i want to watch all together after
watching episodically especially after
i've watched them actually
like i'm done for the day yeah but i do
love me some ryan phillippe so
you do yeah i don't like him cruel
intentions i know and then married to
reese witherspoon and
ava philippi's dad like what sounds like
i don't know
and um he follows me on instagram so
really what's up oh i love him
yeah love him on tuesday abc dropped the
first look at season 25 of the bachelor
which has matt james in the driver's
seat
and his female contestants fawning the
women
are literally falling for you chris
harrison tells james after a woman is
seen tripping while getting
out so the 28 year old that is you like
that's me hitting myself so embarrassing
i was so excited when i saw like matt
james in his suit like
turning i i cause i'm very tall we just
reported that they already
started filming but like they already
started filming no and
there's footage there's visuals on my tv
yeah i was actually shocked at like
the speed in which we got a trailer yeah
no i'm i'm
so excited i think it's gonna be really
great well what i
thought was most interesting about the
trailer is where they were they appeared
to be standing in front of some sort of
mansion looking maybe almost a hotel
like
it was beautiful and it wasn't la quinta
no but was it nemacolin i don't know
i think yeah it's been confirmed pretty
much that they're at nemacolin and
it does look like a mansion looking
hotel it was beautiful and it's like
farm chemin vibes it's gonna be like a
whole new
scene and i'm so excited to like have a
change of scenery
also speaking of a little bachelor t um
people are
and by people i mean to my instagram
account saying that kelly and peter are
like fully engaged
love to see it congratulations mazatov
to the two of you like what an
incredibly strange journey
that is hysterical and yeah ultimately
beautiful yeah cause i actually really
like them as a couple i just think the
way in which he like chose two different
girls neither of which were kelly like
was weird and i didn't like the way that
they came together but if if they had
just won the bachelorette together like
i would have loved them yeah and you
know what like
it's sometimes it's an imperfect thing
and you like
sometimes it's messy but if they found
each other at the end of it and the fact
that they had met before the season they
went to that wedding
right four seasons i think that this is
so sweet i think that they've been
really cute and i think kelly is like
and they wanted the key kelly's probably
one of the like
smartest wizard people that's ever been
on the show so whatever kelly wants
um okay let's dive into our tv recap
segment which last night was the
bachelorette very standard episode
not that much happened um but i did come
to a few conclusions
okay the first conclusion that i came to
is there's always two different types of
bachelorettes
bachelorettes that listen to the
producers and bachelorettes that don't
and i have gathered that tasha is the
bachelorette who listens to the
producers i
thought that felt that way about georgia
fletcher i thought rachel lindsay did
not listen to the producers i thought
caitlin is so to not listen to the
producers
and what i mean by that is like this
whole adverse chasing thing like is
so stupid like lose around loser crime
like i first i'd like to ed for just
calling jason out because jason is such
a loser yeah i actually like dad usually
it's like if you
step in it regardless of what side
you're on like i'm done with both of you
like if you're taking up your time to
talk about drama
but then like what ed was saying about
jason like so specifically yeah it was
the same
adjectives to describe claire and
t-shirt which is like
a pretty legitimate thing to say plus he
was like he's here for instagram
followers and he and
he was just like really going in hard on
him and i was like yeah i see
yeah by the way i was totally with ed
but like he did not let it go
and then he's like such a baby telling
tasha that chasing got aggressive with
him like he was just standing up like
he lost me at the end but at first i was
like living for him coming for jason
because jason is so thirsty
and jason's tick tocks have been coming
up all over my mind
last night i can't see it they're so
aggressive so
it was loser on loser crime and i don't
feel like tasha really has a connection
with either of them but she ended up
keeping
not one but both of them and to me
that's just the producers telling tasha
what to do like she doesn't really care
about these dudes but let's keep them
around for the drama
whereas i feel like a rachel lindsay or
a caitlyn like has absolutely no time
for guys like that
and even though the producers wanted
them to say like they would have sent
both of them home so we could like start
fresh
and not go into next week now talking
about chasing an ed chasing out like
it's so stupid it's not even like an
interesting
um conversation that yeah it's loser on
loser crime and it's not like one of
them is a front runner in any way so
we're not actually concerned about tasha
going
home with the wrong guy right so i felt
as though
that taught me that tasha is listening
to producers and just like doing what
she's supposed to do
and i'm sure after the producer's
working with claire like tasha is a
welcomed
refreshing site for sore eyes yeah but
that was the first conclusion that i
came to
the second conclusion that i came to is
that there are so many front runners
like i cannot decide
who i love more and i don't think tasha
can decide either because i know people
are they're like gearing up for him to
be the
villain but i like love noah yeah i
think he's so cute and i think if you're
cute with a with a mustache on cue
without like you're actually like a
really good looking guy
i think and i didn't i wasn't bothered
at all that he jumped the fence me
neither
no i i think he did a really good job in
the fact that he came on the date midway
through and like still won the rose like
he's obviously an impressive guy i think
he is really cute i don't think he
is a frontrunner because he's just like
kind of young and i
i just feel like he's fun but there are
so many like
ben even though he totally that was the
best thing she shot the bed that was the
best thing that ever happened to me i
really did like him the whole episode
but he was just like you can't he was
too meticulous like you can't plan
a group date like you're five minutes
like he was being a little too cocky and
like just sitting around and i
absolutely loved that he didn't get time
with tasha like even though i like him
and he's definitely a front-runner like
i was living for his failure yeah no it
was funny and it was surprising
and really sad but i do really like him
and i think he's like
top four yes i think he's so i i think
noah while he may not be a winner i
think he's going very far
i think ben is the same i think brendan
who they had the one-on-one i think
they're still like very
like a very strong connection between
him i actually think bennett has like
potential even though
he hasn't been spending like enough time
with tasha alone
and but i think taisha like likes him
yeah there's always like one or two guys
who you could tell have like a real
friendship
with the lead yeah and they will stay
like as long as they possibly
can before like she would have to
eliminate someone that she loves
so i think bennett will be like number
six to go home
yeah me too i think that um were you the
one who told me that he gives you
jean-paul jones vibes
oh did i yeah and that's like obviously
tasha's type yeah
and once ever since you said that i like
can't stop thinking about it so true
like she does have a very unique type
because
john paul jones is like kind of quirky
she likes a quirky guy
and bennett is definitely quirky and i
just have to say like him getting all
those answers wrong at the quiz like
made me like him like i thought it was
so funny so funny and he still won
you know he's so cute so she obviously
likes him if like she was time with him
winning like
yeah even though he didn't participate
in two out of the three yeah but i mean
beignets trump all
speaking of not participating when jason
and ed were supposed to fight
and ed goes over to chris harrison says
he has like dislocated shoulders and
can't fight um i actually was glad that
they didn't fight because something
about the date was giving me like cr
like
i don't like where this is going vibes
like not only like wrestling it's just
so
barbaric but yeah plus like all oiled up
these guys who like
i just i just thought it was it was
stupid it's like
it's 20 20 like yeah and it was already
getting like aggressive like
like they were fighting way harder than
i thought they were going to for guys
who didn't have any beef right so even
though
like it was fine i did i honestly think
that it was way better if
ed and jason did not fight yeah because
there would have been an injury and it's
so
senseless like i agree it's so silly
it's so silly and i thought it was cool
that noah jumped in and also if everyone
wanted to be mad at noah for being on
the date
they should be mad at ed for sitting out
and if noah wants to come to the group
shouldn't be able to shouldn't go
because that like that's who they should
be mad at not noah for seeing an
opportunity and seizing it
that is a wonderful call like just
brilliant like
beyond brilliant ed started to complain
about noah being at the degree
it's your fault [ __ ] like you look in
the mirror no i
look i started the episode like thinking
ed i actually like him and he's a friend
of bennett so i lost he lost me no but
he didn't lose me completely but i i
i don't dislike him yet like i think
that the guys like him i thought
i think he's a fine guy the guy's really
dislike noah like simply because he has
a mustache and he was like the first to
walk in from that new group of guys
which wasn't the first he was no no the
other guy was the first
who he wasn't really in this episode but
he was the one who like
got super aggressive in water polo oh
and then he hurt his mouth was that not
noah no
spencer oh he was like relatively
irrelevant this episode
oh yeah i forgot about him um i just
feel like they don't like him and i
don't like their reasons because he's a
mustache like that ain't fair
yeah that's not a real reason to dislike
someone and now he doesn't even have a
mustache no it looks like next week's
episode it's like all about him
like not right right for her well he is
too young
i know age has no number but like a
taisha keeps saying she wants a boy not
a man
and that means someone older and that
guy's xc who's 36 and he's like
um why am i single in 36 like i actually
really like him yeah i think he will do
well also
even though i don't think he's so cute
yeah but again like i think tasha just
is has like isn't
like her type is just more interest like
she's more interested yeah interesting
and she's like not shallow which i think
makes the season so much more
interesting because it's like the people
who are like the usual classic bachelor
types now like
like moylan is just fading into the
background bye blake boylan i literally
forgot about him also the three men that
that got sent home
never seen them before in my life yeah
i'm sorry to this man like never heard
of him
yeah i'm like you've been here the whole
time yeah crazy
um it was pretty much like a boring
episode but it was classic bachelor
stuff
yeah but in you know old credit to tasha
like it did not
it wasn't a five-hour episode it was a
two-hour yeah no it was it was this
sufficient two-hour episode
and for that tasha we're so grateful and
you're doing great and her looks are
excellent oh my god her looks are
excellent that green dress that she wore
like um
like long sleeve on the date with ashley
and uh jared
oh yeah it was just so cute and like
everything she has is just like cute
yeah no and also that like jumpsuit she
was wearing to the cocktail party
shiny just looked amazing and it's so
like i really feel like she has
chemistry with so many guys and even if
it's like not real chemistry like she's
doing an amazing job of like being the
bachelorette and like i feel like it is
real chemistry though
right i think it is too but just say
like even if like whether it is
we she's at least giving everyone the
time of day and like a really a fair
shot as opposed to just like
judging them based on like what she sees
and like a first impression and then
just writing them off completely
and she's keeping us interested like i
have no idea who's gonna win yeah
and i feel like she could go on a
one-on-one with some random guy that i
literally don't know his name next week
and he's the winner because she's just
like
she's so radiant like she gives out
you're right like she sees the best and
everyone and everyone is obsessed with
her shut the [ __ ] up my god we're trying
to record a podcast
it's truckers ferticia they come out
every week
i forgot about that that's true sorry i
didn't mean to yell truckers for tasha
choo choo um so yes i feel like if i if
you were doing a
what do they call it espn bracket
yes who would be your top four
oh okay um ben
i think i'm trying to remember
everyone's name it's so hard ben zaksey
um i guess that guy brendan
yeah who's also divorced and
who's like an obvious i feel like
someone that she hasn't like really
sparked with yet that we haven't seen
you know like noah no i don't think noah
i don't know i'm so bad at predicting
these like if it was me like i literally
would have predicted ed like i'm so bad
oh and ivan oh yes he got the rose this
week he's cute
yeah really cute and i think that and
but quiet yeah
um okay well we'll see we'll watch that
in six weeks and see what happens
um now up for dear toasters which is our
advice segment
so we do dear toasters every wednesday
and you can always email us dear
toasters
gmail.com we'll always keep it anonymous
if you have anything you want to write
in about
relationship stuff best friend stuff
wedding stuff vagina stuff i don't know
we've gotten some weird [ __ ] over the
years
um and dear toasters is brought to you
by stamps.com
this holiday season more people will be
mailing stuff than ever before
that means that the post office is going
to be busy you don't have time for that
nobody does
stamps.com brings the post office and
now ups shipping right to your computer
mail and ship anything from the
convenience of your home or office
with stamps.com anything you can do at
the post office you can do with just a
few clicks
plus stamps.com saves you money with
deep discounts that you can't even get
at the post office
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send
once your mail is ready just schedule a
pick up to drop it and or drop it off
it's that simple plus with stamps.com
you get five cents off of every first
class stamp
and up to 40 off priority mail and up to
62 percent off ups
shipping rates don't spend a minute your
holiday season at the post office this
year
sign up for stamps.com instead there's
no risk with our promo code toast you
get a special offer that includes a
four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in
toast that's stamps.com enter
toaststamps.com never go to the post
office again
love that all right dear toasters here
we go dear claudia and jackie
thank you for bringing a smile to my
face every weekday at approximately 10
30 a.m eastern time
my sorority sister let's call her maddie
just got engaged and asked me to be a
bridesmaid in her wedding
she's such a precious gem of a woman but
here's the thing maddie and my boyfriend
peter hooked up in college before we
date it not only that but she actually
peed in his bed
they were so drunk that she peed in his
bed twice she legit peed on my boyfriend
like a pup on a fire hydrant marking her
territory with actual urine
it still bothers me a little bit but i
know it's completely irrational it's
been years and she's literally marrying
someone else but i can't let it go
i actually have a photo of them making
out on my phone to remind me in case my
temp
my terrible memory fails me and i need
to take it out and use it against them
one day
they've barely spoken in years and she
will likely attend our future wedding
one day
but it's so weird to me that he may be
going to her wedding because the only
tie they have to each other
is that they used to hook up she gave me
a plus one so should i bring him to the
wedding anyways or just leave him at
home so i take care of my bridesmaids
duties
and possibly avoid a weird drunken
encounter and a lot of social anxiety
thanks in advance a day one toaster this
is tough because like part of me thinks
you're being irrational but like i kind
of understand and
i don't know girls i feel like girls who
end up marrying like their
college boyfriends like people do the
craziest [ __ ] in college yeah you all
know each other like it's definitely
toxic
yeah no i think that on the
i don't think there's anything here like
when you went to college with your
friends and
you're dating someone from college like
there's gonna be stories there like
everyone made out with everyone like you
just kissed a lot of frogs
that's just what you did um i don't
think like
she's literally getting married you're
the only reason that he and she are even
connected anymore
if you don't want to bring him i think
that's an overreaction like you guys
should have a fun night at a wedding
together right don't deprive yourself i
think
i don't i don't there's nothing that
she's said or done that
should make you think like she's still
like holding a torch for him i mean
she's literally
getting married or vice versa like i
just if you
if you want to date someone that you
went to college with like you have to
accept all of that baggage whether it be
like from your friends and and that's a
tough
pill to swallow very and i'm not saying
that i would be able to do it
but that's just you've made your bed
now you got to pee in it yeah that's
just the price to pay if you want to
date someone you went to college with
yeah and jackie's right like this girl's
done nothing like
just bring your boyfriend it's fine and
she's your friend and just drink a lot
like it'll be a fun wedding with all
your college friends like you don't want
your boyfriend to miss out on that
yeah that sounds so fun that sounds so
fun but i think you've got to put it in
the past
me too put it to bed otherwise it's just
going to
continually consume you and it's like if
there's nothing there it's eating at you
for no reason
right that's one of those things where
it's like your anxiety gets the best of
you and even though there's like no good
reason for it like it can ruin
parts of your life like you've got to
get stressing over nothing like if there
were things that you had seen
that just kicked your intuition into
high gear being like there's something
between them but there's nothing like
that it's just the fact that like
she hooked up with him and peed in his
bed twice like i think
yeah i think he's seen what he wants to
see and he wants to be with you not the
girl who peed in his bed
twice twice um okay next up hey jackie
and claudia
recently my fiance's best friend judas
told us he was moving away
on judas's last week before moving my
fiance
tried multiple times to hang out with
judas so he could officially ask him to
be his best man
judas never responded to the texts then
i received a phone call from judas i
thought it was weird but i assumed it
was to explain why he's been avoiding my
fiance
judas got right to the point of why he
called to tell me he was in love with me
[ __ ] what i made it very clear that i
only have love for my fiance and nobody
else
he was adamant on spilling his feelings
and said he just had to tell me before
he moved tomorrow
he talked about keeping this
conversation between us in a panic i
lied and said i wouldn't tell my fiance
we awkwardly hung up and i burst into
tears
this like [ __ ] never happens to me like
why don't people call me and tell me
that they love me
the worst part was having to tell my
fiance all in all my fiance deserves a
purple heart for the way he handled this
we decided to not reach out to judas
since he was moving the next day
we wanted him to just leave and then we
could figure it out from there two
months later judas hasn't reached out to
us
my question is should we just let this
one go are we letting him off easy i'm
pissed that you just dropped this
bombshell
and then went on his merry [ __ ] way
while the rest of us are just picking up
the rubble
sincerely the horror story version of
love actually
i don't know it seems like he did you a
favor like okay he had these feelings
which were inappropriate but not his
fault
and then he ghosted you like great and
now you and your husband have a great
relationship
like you were honest with him your
husband like it seems like you guys are
on the same team and then judas just
made himself disappear like yeah unless
he's not what do you want him to be
calling you up every day checking in to
see if you changed your mind like
he had to unburden himself like you have
to hear that someone's in love with you
like how fabulous for you
and now your husband your fiance is
probably like on his toes a little bit
like
oh she could always go for judas like no
and it's like i'm married like
this hot thing like that everyone wants
this is a win-win-win
100 except for judas of course of course
but he moved and he's going to start a
new life for himself do you think he
moved
because of this maybe he couldn't handle
it but yeah look he took himself out of
the equation like
very selfless i think he handled this
perfectly i think so too and i think
that
yeah you could say maybe he shouldn't
have told you but i'm sure
like one he needed to get it off his
chest and two on the small chance that
you felt the same way
he would never know if he never said it
unfortunately you don't feel the same
way
because you say it you gotta take risks
you gotta take risks all right
at the end of the day this is like that
episode of friends where rachel wants to
tell ross that she's in love with him
and everyone's like
don't do it don't do it and she's like
why because at the end of the day like
it's always nice to be like told that
someone is in love with you and it's
like
i would just take the compliment
girlfriend and then go back to like you
and your husband's like
what seems to be a perfectly happy life
together 100 this this doesn't sound
like you need advice at all it sounds
like you're bragging
like this sounds amazing i'm so happy
for you like you have an amazing husband
you're so loved
who's so brave and like handled this
awkward situation and then you found out
like some other like probably good
looking guys in love with you like
this is so much so that he had to leave
town yeah it's so much so that you had
to write into a podcast to brag about it
like honestly i don't see the problem i
don't see the problem here
all right our third and final one hi
claudia and jackie first off i love you
guys so much and want to say thank you
for getting me through quarantine oh my
god you're welcome we love you too
so much now for the important part my
boyfriend and i have been together for
over three years now and i'm fairly
certain that he's the one
we talk about our future together all
the time and though we have issues like
any other couple i think we are a good
match
here's where things get interesting i
had a psychic reading done
i can't take people seriously i had a
psychic reading done once
done recently at my sister's
bachelorette party everything she said
was so on point for me without giving me
any hints or information about myself
she pulled a card for me that said i was
going to marry the man of my dreams and
we would be
so madly in love with each other and
happy i asked whether or not this man of
my dreams was already in my life and she
said no
i know this is crazy this is crazy and
most people think psychics are [ __ ]
but i can't stop thinking about this it
would be insane to break up with someone
over
something a random psychic said but am i
going to live the rest of my life
wondering whether or not the man of my
dreams is still out there
help a psyched-out toaster okay like
i understand why you might want to take
this psychics advice to heart and i
think that you should but if you break
up with your
boyfriend to go meet the man of your
dreams like you're making
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy like
you're doing it because she said like
it comes true because she told you to do
it like she put this in your head
yeah and so you're gonna go and make it
happen and then it's like this next guy
who could be terrible but you're like
he's the man of my dreams
yeah but like he it's just it's the
definition you're making it come true
because
it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy i
think that you should continue on with
your life as planned
you never know what will happen like you
could always keep that in the back of
your mind but actually don't even like
it'll ruin your relationship until you
break up with him to go see what's out
there and like you'll make the
psychics prophecy come true just put it
away for now
in 10 years look back and see what
happened yeah also to me there's like
two realms of possible two possibilities
here one
you marry this man and then like you
always think like oh that psychic said i
could have met someone else
or you leave this man and never find
anyone and then you think about how a
psychic ruined your life
so i would just stick with the man that
you have now because there seems to be
absolutely no problems here and you're
making something out of nothing okay
yeah i don't i think that like any time
you get a psychics advice like
definitely like take it to heart
consider it
um but don't like change your life plans
based on it if you really like thought
something else beforehand
yeah you know i don't believe in
psychics that much i think that they're
interesting right
i think there are some people who get
like crazy readings that like tell them
everything that and it winds up coming
true
but it doesn't come true because they
made it come true because the psychic
told them too like they just happened to
reflect on me like oh yeah that did
happen
yeah and now we're on a steamboat so
that is our show that was your toaster
thank you guys for writing in
and thank you so much for listening to
the morning toast millennial morning
show where you deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so it's
spotify itunes central public radio i
have rated catbox all the places where
we listen to podcasts find out morning
toast and leave a five star review about
our beautiful stunning and smart we are
we hope you have an amazing day we'll
see you tomorrow for the second half of
the week thank god goodbye goodbye